good morning everyone and welcome to
this session on building effective data
science teams I'm so happy to see you
all here um we'll have a host of
fantastic speakers each one will have 20
minutes today um that includes question
if time permits and it is my great
pleasure to welcome the first Speaker
Daniel Woody up to the stage please come
in
[Applause]
[Music]
all right uh thanks everyone um I have
to start this off with a little story um
so actually last week I was having a
meeting with my manager and we were
doing like a performance review
check-in um and he had lots of positive
feedback about you know how I'm building
this prototyping competency within Lily
and you know I've done a great job with
coming up with like an operating model
and having metrics for the team and
setting the direction um but he gave me
some feedback too on things to improve
on and um the the thing to improve on is
uh my presentation skills and so um this
is a great opportunity to um you know
put some of that to work but so that was
Tuesday of last week and then Wednesday
of last week I get on the you know get
on LinkedIn get on the internet and I I
see this um you know mus haves for this
conference is my talk and then this
company put out a top 10 and put my talk
as number one and I was like um we need
a level set a little bit here guys um so
yeah just putting that putting that out
there um so thanks everyone for coming
to the talk today um here's the the
rough agenda so I'll be going over you
know why a build a prototyping
capability um something I've put
together uh I'm calling the St
statistical Sciences hierarchy of needs
uh based on you know maso's hierarchy of
needs um I'm going to walk through our
process a little bit uh how we Define a
prototype um how we operate as a team
and Lessons Learned um and one thing
I'll point out is um when I say like we
as a team it's uh it's me and one other
guy um we are very Scrappy operation um
so yeah which I like we're able to to um
deliver uh real
fast um so yeah on the topic of why to
build a prototyping capability um you
know they're useful and quickly vetting
new ideas um so I work in Pharma and the
stats
department and uh Innovation can be hard
in that group and a lot of it is there's
just a fear of risk-taking and having
the prototyping capability allows you to
quickly vet you know uh new technologies
that you may want to explore uh and it
really provides an accelerator to the
broader strategy for the
organization um and so yeah it's uh
incredibly valuable for elevating the
conversation um not just with your team
but with leadership um because a lot of
times they like to go big and it slows
them down whereas going small allows
them to you know test out these new
ideas in kind of a risk averse
way um yeah so the statistical science
is hierarchy of needs um so uh if you've
seen maso's hierarchy of needs it's you
know based on that obviously uh which is
a schema or framework for um kind of
finding you know fulfillment and and
being healthy and you know when applying
it to um our
organization this is kind of my latest
draft with it it's always kind of
updating but um yeah for us we uh we
have it infrastructure at the foundation
of it uh which can be kind of uh foreign
I think to people that are traditional
statisticians um but yeah um it is kind
of the the Bedrock for everything else
that we do and having that value and
perspective is kind of critical to
progress in the other layers and so you
know once you have you know something in
place or strategy in place for moving it
infrastructure forward then you can
start to look at like your tools and
your capabilities um and so for us the
tools are building our packages shiny
applications
um and on the capability side it's you
know we work with um drug development
teams and so we're working on clinical
trials and so it's kind of taking those
tools and using them for those um
product
teams and then beyond that we also have
training um and so once you have kind of
your tools narrowed down then you're
looking at okay how do you upskill the
organization uh which is a which is a
big task um
and then beyond that we have the
prototypes team and so with the
prototypes team like I've said we're an
accelerator um and so we're working in
it infrastructure we're working in the
tools and capabilities and we're even
testing out new training
modalities and our job is really to um
make those lower levels kind of work in
harmony better and then at the top you
have self-actualization or yeah just
everything working
in the direction you want it to
so that is kind of our our North Star if
you will um so our process very simple
um I point this out because a lot of
times people can get lost in
technology and say oh I've got you know
this new hammer and then they just go
and find the nails but you know that may
not be uh the best way to start out and
so
um so yeah uh obviously find the problem
once you have the problem solve it in
some way that could be with some new
technology that's our lean on it
um beyond that get paid SL reduce cost
uh and then lastly refine and repeat so
that's our uh that's that's kind of how
we stay uh practical I guess with all of
our Solutions
um one example
prototype uh you know walking through or
framing it that same way um so one issue
if you built chiny applications is that
they will freeze when running a long
running job um and you know the
application will just stop working um
and so the solution to that is uh to use
or to enable uh asynchron
processing uh there's a variety of ways
to do that um so at Lily there's a great
developer will landow he's made a number
of tools one is crew which helps to
facilitate um spending up independent
workers and running a a job from an
existing R session um and so we put
together a basic prototype to see could
this solve our problem and if so you
know
what does that look like um so we built
it uh on our in this case we didn't
necessarily get paid um but it does
Drive Impact by making the applications
more usable and broadening our impact uh
and then lastly uh on the step for
refining and
repeating um it was open- sourced and
people continued to build on it um and
the direction our team has
gone um has has been to enable
offloading those independent workers
into new Compu environment so that's how
we iterate
um yeah and so on the topic of what is a
prototype um it's important to Define
what your Finish Line is uh because you
don't just want to blindly be going out
and building a prototype and without
much direction or aim kind of at just
continuing to iterate
um and so for us the finish line is
typically you know either it's a pre
pre-specified set of features um
oftentimes it's a guidance on go or noo
uh for future
development um or uh in that same vein
uh providing the guidance on okay if you
want to mature the software um what
would that take to move it to the next
stage
um yeah and moving on
so um this is a scorecard that we've put
together as a team to Define what those
other stages look like um and so in the
leftmost column uh you have uh the
software maturity stage uh so we we end
up spending most of our time in the POC
or functional prototype um but then you
can move on to you know alpha or beta
releases where you're uh broadening out
uh that uh enduser group or uh
eventually taking it onto production
software where people are using it uh to
make important
decisions and so going from that
leftmost column moving over um we have
things like uh having in user testing
you know the
documentation uh more unit testing
integration testing and working with it
as well um but yeah like I said we spend
most of our time in the POC to alpha or
beta release uh and then when it comes
to moving things on to production um
usually we'll we'll simply provide the
guidance and start working with the
teams for a handoff or something like
that all
right and
so uh moving on to how we operate as a
team um so again it's just me James the
other guy um um we check in Daily um we
don't have a project manager we project
manage ourselves um
and um typically we're working on two to
three prototypes at a time um and they
take anywhere from a few weeks to a few
months to
complete um as far as setting goals as a
team uh we use the objectives and key
results framework um and so every
quarter we kind of set some big picture
goals uh for example one is uh to
complete 10 prototypes in the next
quarter um as a team and that allows us
it's a good mix of kind of long and
short-term goals uh so we have three
months to work on those prototypes but
then we have a lot of flexibility in
between and defining what those
prototypes are uh what teams or groups
we're working with uh
yeah another thing we do is we make our
goals widely available and at those
quarterly check-ins uh we meet with a
lot of the sponsors for the team or the
stakeholders and reset the goals um we
make our goals widely available um so
anyone can look at them provide input to
them um yeah and then lastly um this is
a fun one or at least I I think it's a
fun one um we also do a retrospective
and we do something called a fear
setting exercise I saw it in a TED Talk
and tried it out and we've been doing
we've done a few now um and we did this
fear setting so it's if you haven't seen
it or or heard about it it's kind of the
opposite of goal setting um yeah which
my I think uh scared my manager when I
first pitched it um yeah so fear setting
it's useful for someone like me so I'm
very op optimistic but I also like
taking risk and so that can be trouble
um because those anxieties or like that
voice in your head saying like no don't
do it can be useful um and so the fear
setting um kind of facilitates that so
what we'll do um is we'll talk about
ways that our group like something could
go wrong um or you know one example
would be like we start working with a
certain team and you know they want to
use all of our resources and so we can't
really work on the other stuff so you
know that's a big fear we don't just
want to be a shop for like one team um
and so you know going beyond that fear
it's not just like we talk about them
and then we get paralyzed by them um
then we talk about okay what if that did
happen you know what do we do um or yeah
what can we introduce maybe to our goals
to make sure that that kind of thing
isn't happening so yeah and another fun
part of that is like I said I lean
towards more like being
optimistic and there's definitely
some uh I don't know there's there's
people that are on the other side of
that Spectrum more um cautious more
anxious a lot of fears um and it's fun
to recruit them
because um I rely on that because I'm
like I don't you know honestly I don't
even know what I have a blind spot I
don't know what my fears should be um
and so yeah relying on them is really
valuable um and I yeah uh yeah the the
guy I'm thinking about I was skeptical I
was like I don't even know if he's going
to want to join this but he had a blast
and keep showing up to him so um
yeah all righty and uh lastly just to
share some of the Lessons Learned um uh
like I mentioned earlier conversation
around Innovation will be
elevated um I think it's in the spirit
of organizations transitioning from
waterfall to Agile but uh instead of
taking gigantic you know multi-year
projects uh that have a lot of risk and
um yeah uh you can balance that with um
doing smaller projects testing the
waters learning more about it and yeah
lifting up the entire conversation both
on the development side and within
leadership
um let's see so you will uh fail often
uh but more than make up for it with
reducing cost and uh accelerating
learning uh yeah I think as a team this
is going to sound strange but I wish we
failed more um and I think my manager
has said uh we should fail more um and
we do fail but I think when you're
failing more you're taking uh you know
you're you're pushing the boundaries
more and so that's a that's an important
part of it um and Beyond failing you
know obviously you're learning from
those uh those uh
prototypes um as I mentioned earlier
it's a very small team uh I really think
you can do a lot with a small Scrappy
team um especially in that earlier phase
uh for software maturity when you're
talking about production software
there's more important things than uh
moving fast necessarily uh you want
reliability and quality with a lot of
that stuff uh it's harder to move faster
with a big team um and also with older
more mature software it's harder to make
the updates so that's where having yeah
prototypes is really Val
valuable next I'd say inter it iteration
is not just for software it's really
good for metrics as well so earlier I
mentioned one of our metrics or goals is
to uh complete 10 prototypes of quarter
and some of you may have listened to
that and said well that's not a really
good metric um and it's one we work on
too uh so um there's certainly different
flavors of what that metric could be uh
um uh right now it's a good volume we're
adjusting it but yeah one thing that has
come out of this is that those metrics
need to be
updated we revisit them on a quarterly
basis but yeah it's good to have that
flexibility to iterate on metrics as
well next uh spending some time with
your fears is incredibly
valuable um yeah I think you know I
shared earlier how it's good for people
that lean towards being more
optimistic um but I think it's also good
for people that spend more time with
their anxieties uh because it kind of
forces people to go you know from those
fears to like okay let's say it does
happen then what and you're not just
stuck in that you know cycle of thinking
about what could potentially go
wrong uh experimenting early and often
is a huge accelerator um yeah can't
emphasize that enough uh and then lastly
I would say uh statisticians are
becoming software developers that's a
big uh narrative within our organization
and having the prototypes team exist to
bridge that Gap uh is is very valuable
um I think we're key to um testing and
vetting the new ideas new technologies
new processes is that the rest of the
organization is um starting to test the
waters with and we get to be the guinea
pigs to share those learnings out so y
all right well that is all I have so
thank you everyone for coming to the
talk
today thank you Daniel yeah we will have
time for a single question um and so it
must be really tempting to keep working
the Prototype to production how do you
decide when enough is
enough
um that is a great question um we
haven't been forced that yet
um yeah when to decide when to move like
a prototype to production so a lot of it
ends up coming so we'll provide like I
said a go or no-o decision and then
we'll do some evaluation on like okay
you want to take it to the next phase um
you know here's what that would take and
our team really isn't set up for
supporting you know uh the QA process
with it uh monitoring infrastructure
things like that so yeah I think having
that conversation early and upfront is
important um because that's definitely
the direction it would go is and we
don't want to be a team that is just
supporting the production software um it
stops us from accelerating those
conversations
so fantastic thank you again Daniel yep
[Applause]
thanks